this video is sponsored by data lane as
a youtuber who makes videos about the
Earth's environment and specifically
climate I receive a lot of comments from
people who dispute the influence
humanity has on the natural world one
particular argument which gets brought
up again and again is something along
the lines of why haven't sea levels
risen a frequent prediction of
anthropogenic climate change is that
mean sea levels will rise threatening
coastal communities causing mass
migration and apparently the end of the
world it certainly doesn't feel like
that's happened so in this video let's
review the data on global sea levels and
work out if humans are actually changing
anything
first of all let's look at some data
from coastal tide gauges satellite data
nothing fancy an actual physical set of
gauges at multiple locations around the
world do these measurements show any sea
level oh wow yeah they do the gauge is
shown early 25 centimetres of mean sea
level rise from 1880 to 2013 sea levels
have been rising a lot but the term sea
level rise isn't actually terribly
useful when talking about climate change
because if you look at historical data
from among other things coral cause it's
clear that mean sea levels have been
rising for around 20,000 years as this
figure suggests this is a result of the
earth coming out of the last glacial
maximum what you might call the most
recent ice age about 20,000 years ago
the earth started warming largely due to
cyclical variations in its orbit around
the Sun called Milankovitch cycles
though there were likely other factors
as the earth warmed which we can see
very clearly in proxy data like ice
cores sea levels rose rapidly due to ice
sheets melting and pouring into the
ocean basins water that previously been
locked up as ice including a huge amount
as ice on land enter the oceans and
increase their volume when these ice
sheets retreated the landscape
significantly changed making for example
the British Isles separate from mainland
Europe returning to the figure with very
much at the tail end of this
interglacial sea level rise which
appears to be either completely static
or decreasing in pace but still changing
the mean sea level a smart question to
us then is given this background sea
level rise the earth coming out of the
last glacial maximum has humanity
changed the rate of sea level rise in
other words by influence in the climate
through
in greenhouse gases like co2 have we as
a species accelerated sea-level rise
well we have a time series of mean sea
level stretching back to 1880 the
hypothesis is that humans have increased
the rate of sea level rise since then in
terms of this graph that the rate of
sea-level rise the slope is greater at
the end of the time series than at the
start
clearly the sea level hasn't risen by
the same amount every year there are
plenty of Wiggles so let's take an
average over a long period of time let's
compare the average sea level rise in
the first 30 years of data to the
average sea level rise and the last 30
years of data if I was being rigorous
then I'd test if my conclusions were
sensitive to the length of time
considered but I leave that as an
exercise for the bureau in the first 30
years sea level rose by an average of
one point three one millimeters per year
in the last thirty years the sea level
rose by two point five millimeters per
year so what could have caused this
increase factors which unknown to have
caused previous sea level change
Milankovitch cycles and continental
drift operate on long timescales and
haven't been observed to change
significantly over the past century
another mechanism that could force this
increase is variation in solar outputs
the total solar irradiance over the past
century this has increased but by less
than nine point one percent not enough
to have forced observed acceleration of
sea level rise that leaves one further
mechanism known to alter sea levels
changes in radiative forcing over the
past century the concentration of
radiatively active greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere have changed
significantly due to human emissions
altering the Earth's energy budget the
resulting increase in global average
temperature causes both increased melt
of ice sheets like Antarctica and
Greenland but also thermal expansion of
the oceans if you heat up water it
expands in volume ever so slightly this
is well known physics this isn't
noticeable on small scales but when you
expand an entire ocean ever-so-slightly
the results are absolutely measurable so
we have observational evidence that sea
level rise has accelerated and that
natural forcings have not varied
sufficiently on the timescale of
observations therefore were left to
conclude that our hypothesis that humans
have accelerated sea level rise is
correct but this was just me
messing around with one time series for
10 minutes
there is an entire scientific literature
using lots of data sources including
global satellite altimetry because sea
level rise isn't the same everywhere and
more powerful statistical techniques to
establish that yes
sea levels started rising more rapidly
around the turn of the 20th century and
that this rate of change has likely
continually increased over the past 100
years so we can be pretty sure that
humans have accelerated global sea level
rise but only by a couple of millimeters
per year
that hardly matches up with the
predictions of the future looking like
Kevin Costner's Waterworld
by which I mean terrible well there are
two parts as to why firstly no serious
scientist has claimed that we would all
be underwater or living on [ __ ] or
trimarans by the present day many of the
scientific predictions that are mocked
by climate change deniers have either
been hiked out of all recognition from
serious research or outright fabricated
I had a mate who used to do exactly this
he would hype up stories about me to the
point where he could start mocking me
for spreading such outlandish tales
about myself to our friends for the
record for those of you who knew me from
uni I never actually single-handedly
saved a girl from drowning by abseiling
bare-chested into the river that that
was Rob's version of the story secondly
previous predictions of sea level rise
actually match up fairly well with what
we've observed the very first IPCC
report in 1990 made a series of
predictions of sea level rise by the
present day and satellite observations
are right in the middle of their
predictions for the first 26 years
showing slightly less sea level rise
than their best guess at the time
current estimates still have
uncertainties attached but much smaller
ones as we understand the systems much
better and as our models for predicting
sea level rise add new complexity and
more physical systems our estimates as
well as getting more accurate get higher
and higher it's considered very likely
that sea levels in the year 2100 will be
between 30 and 130 centimeters higher
than in the year 2000 and a lot of
scientists consider that to be too
conservative an estimate in other words
the acceleration of sea level rise that
we've observed humans calls to date is
only the thin
end of the wedge sea levels are going to
rise faster and faster every decade and
by the end of the century the impacts
are going to be very real so to answer
the question in the videos title sea
levels have been rising every decade and
in fact the sea level has been rising
faster every decade scientists
understand the physical systems behind
this increase in sea level and have seen
their predictions borne out by
observations thus far and the
acceleration of sea level rise that we
humans cause is going to continue for
the foreseeable future committing us to
potentially more than a metre of sea
level rise by the end of the century
this will put coastal populations at
risk of inundation species at risk of
extinction something we think that's
pretty happened naturally and economies
around the world especially those of
island nations at risk of going under
and that's just this century we are
committed to further warming and further
sea level rise for centuries to come
every tonne of greenhouse gas that we
emit into the atmosphere now only makes
that long-term change worse we can of
course adapt to changes in our
environment we are a hardy species but
why make the lives of our descendants
generations yet unborn more difficult
perhaps even impossibly difficult when
we can take action now see the
description for my video on what we can
do today to enable meaningful change in
our climate outlook
thanks to dashlane also linked in the
description for supporting my climate
change based content on this channel
their support allows me to make videos
like this one - Lane is a service that
keeps you safe online by generating
extremely strong passwords for your
various online accounts and then
remembering them for you only you have
access to your store of passwords which
are accessible with your unique master
password and they're kept safe and
secure behind patented security software
your passwords absolutely essential to
digital life are better with dashlane
and they are safer with dashlane you can
use it for free on one device and I
would absolutely recommend at least
trying it out but if you upgrade to
premium then you can have - Lane synced
across all your devices PC laptop phone
tablet you name it and the app and
browser extension otter
films forms for you even if you have
multiple accounts on the same service
both I and my girlfriend use it and I
would honestly highly recommend the
service I've got nothing but positive
things to say if you'd like to try
premium then go to - link comm slash
Simon Clark and use the promo code
Simon Clark to get a 10% discount thank
you for watching the video
I'm sure the comments are completely
civil check out the links on the screen
to my other science videos and if you
like the stuff that I make please
consider sharing the video and
subscribing to be notified of new
uploads thank you again and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]